Ludovic vigogne c'est 100 jours là c'est
son premier jour hein du second mandat
c'est ce que vous racontez dans notre
livre 100 jours SAS c'est le titre c'est
quoi c'est comme un vide comme un blanc
tout à fait il y a un c'est un passage à
vide c'est un homme qui réussit un
exploit un président qui réussit à être
élu qui alors qu'il avait la majorité
absolue contrairement à François
Mitterrand 88 et a Jacques Chirac en
et en même temps un homme qui traverse
un passage à vide en prenant des
décisions stratégiques qui se révèleront
extrêmement mauvaises on ne parvenant
pas à nommer la première ministre qui
n'a initialement choisie on se voyant
refuser par les francines majorité
absolue à l'Assemblée nationale alors
qu'Emmanuel Macron ne doutait pas une
seule seconde qu'il obtiendrait
facilement voilà c'est un moment où le
président prend des décisions que ses
proches te comprennent pas ou son
entourage des Arsen comme s'il avait pas
anticipé sa réélection oui vous diriez
ça c'est sûr alors les sondages le le
donne des vainqueur donc Emmanuel Macron
pendant tout son premier mandat a pensé
chaque jour à sa réélection il a pensé
chaque jour c'était son obsession et en
fait il s'est retrouvé le 24 avril et
lui il avait pas du tout anticipé
préparait le jour d'après et donc c'est
pour ça qu'il décide de prendre son
temps de laisser la poussière retomber
il n'avait pas du tout imaginé à la
personne qui pourrait la Matignon à la
configuration de son gouvernement il se
retrouve un peu démuni dès le lendemain
de sa